foreign
this is what just moving between cities
in China has looked like at any domestic
station or airport covered codes tests
and cues just one part of a dominating
system now being dismantled in theory
there'll be an end to mass testing an
end to scanning digital Health codes to
enter most businesses
okay
according to the rules I don't
officially have to do this anymore
but we're still being made to show our
codes seriously it hadn't wholly
trickled down yet
come at a time that infections are
surging this the cue for a fever Clinic
full the pandemic worker tells them
those who'd waited for hours were angry
many here told us they couldn't access
home testing there was uncertainty about
easing
sounds
her mother interrupted she disagrees
foreign
the focus is Shifting to medicating at
home no centralized quarantine for the
asymptomatic no more bands on cold and
flu medicine many rushed to pharmacies
to bulk by aware of what's likely coming
up
it will likely take a long time for
things to properly get back to normal
here and there are still a lot of rules
and regulations that remain but it feels
like there's been a fundamental shift in
the government's assessment that
allowing some people to become infected
and die of covert is now less
destabilizing than zero covert itself
it's last week's rare protests that
seemed to have prompted it but it's
still a major risk a large population
and a weak hospital system many may die
zero covert has been a flagship here few
thought it would be so suddenly scrapped
Helena Smith Sky News in Beijing